hey guys it is the 21st of sep tember my
name is Jess and you're watching
gamespot news first up Dark Souls
developer from software has confirmed
that a new armored core title is on the
way from software boss hit attack in
Miyazaki said we are making a new
armored core title we're still in the
early stages of development when pressed
for further details on how far along
they are in development Miyazaki simply
said he couldn't talk about it the last
entry in the mech focused Armored Core
Series came out in 2013 Miyazaki also
confirmed that from software is working
on a project that he described as a
little weird he explained when I say
weird the genre might be a little weird
the game is weird but we are diligently
making it in all seriousness so I just
want people to know that when they think
it's strange he added the Dark Souls 3
is the last game in the series he plans
to work on but that doesn't mean the end
for dark souls hi res bus todd harris
has come out to say that overwatch was
not the inspiration for their game
paladins the response comes after a
video went viral that implies paladin's
is an overwatch clone Harris told IGN
that cactus her bear a resemblance to
those in overwatch were available and
playable in the Paladins beta long
before similar character abilities was
shown in overwatch the closed beta for
paladin started in November 2015 while /
Watchers closed beta period began in
October 2015 if you want to dig into the
nitty-gritty of this one Harris has
written a lengthy log post on reddit
detailing the timeline of paladins
development which while insightful
probably won't stop the overwatch fans
among you from logging on to overwatch
instead of paladins finally Microsoft
has had a bit of a shot at the ps4 pro
today for not being happy enough to
handle 4k Microsoft's Albert Penello
told Eurogamer that the 4.2 teraflops of
performance boasted by the PS walk pro
is not enough to do true 4k Pinello also
said I think there are a lots of caveats
they're giving customers right now
around 4k they're talking about
checkerboard rendering and upscaling and
things like that there are just a lot of
asterisks in there
marketing around 4k which is interesting
because when we thought about what spec
we wanted for Scorpio we were very clear
we want to develop this to take their
xbox one engines and render them in
native true 4k sony has made it clear
that the majority of ps4 pro games will
be upscaled 24 cake as opposed to being
rendered natively at that mark canola
goes on to say I feel like our product
aspired a little bit higher and we will
have fewer asterisks around the 4k
experiences we deliver on our box we're
building a great platform we're building
the most powerful console ever made
we're doing a lot of work with
developers to allow them to harness that
power you should let me know what you
thought of today's stories down in that
comment section head to gain [ __ ] for
stories on Marine Corps and mafia three
and I will see you again tomorrow